alors massimo gargia depuis dix ans que
je te rencontre pour toutes les soirées
parisiennes se demande ce que tu fais
alors là tu veux en profiter pour vous
expliquer oui beaucoup déjà cédé m'avait
fait je fais une chose très serré je
fais un jour même pour les bus qui sort
quatre fois par mois j'ai beaucoup
d'espèces auprès de test est consacré et
gens riches et célèbres non non c'est
consacrer beaucoup aussi à la montre et
j'ai des grands ducs équipements qu'on
m'aura bien comme ça quand même
peyrefitte way pour le sourire gêné
décrivait ça va tout le monde et guo
natif rigolade effet de patrick dont le
départ est plus marquée pour saint jean
qui liquidités ou à paris un accusé est
pas le message si tu fais avec et en
fumant dans le monde entier oui partout
à la mairie bartho qui alors dans le
prochain numéro sûr qu'on les prochains
numéros ses bières et autres
photographes hier monde
cependant quelques points et le nouvel
os d'autant que cela dure encore sur la
couverture
photographiée par qui toujours débout
oui bon je n'en ai dit que j'ai fait
tous les coups
moi c'est pour moi aussi ça s'est passé
comment et john collins a très bien les
traits fins gris qu'elle a tout à
l'heure dans l'addiction est très simple
et facile d avis d'abord alors moi je
travaille avec les amis que tout sépare
sauf la couverture mais d'aller passer
soraya il a pu se révéler d'origine et
sont tous des amis alors c'est amusant
contre moi je pourrais jamais faire le
travail que je n'aime pas j'ai jamais
trop aimé beaucoup de travail je me suis
amusé jusqu'à l'âge de 35 ans un désert
et avant elle mange bien je suis voilée
c'est le mental qui était de 10 ans
bondit avec nous mêmes mots qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité
c'était comme un peu un peu de retard et
un ami et le nom j'ai commencé à
travailler sérieusement et sur chose qui
va mieux sur les mains mais comment tu
fais pour être aussi aînés tous ces gens
là bas parce que justement avant j'ai
voyagé débordante et je les connais ils
sont confiants même avant le même avant
qu'il met en confiance parce que si on
était des amis avant tout en cessant la
porte
ça demande beaucoup de travail
d'entretien entretien quand même tu les
as mais la maison oui parce que c'est un
vu c'est un gros travail c'était comme
un gamin devant sécurité et
donc je laisse apercevoir la vie libre
est aussi financier j'entretiens des
relations tu veux dire assez
intéressante chaque fois qu'ils se
soient l'avait vu ce que vous faire un
enfant - s'est ouvert satisfaction c'est
la seule chose qui va mieux et s'est
vendu combien combien ça va nous
échapper à la can à 1 40 euro beaucoup
d'argent alors non je savais très bien
que ces jeunes et les vieux
c'est dans la loi il faut être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou